let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750.
Let's go first to Jose, who we have not heard
from, uh, since January.
Uh, Oh.
So what's going on?
Hey, what's up David?
How you doing?
Good.
How are you?
I'm doing good.
Hell, I want to hear your thoughts on a book
fascination of of this administration using
the military as pawn.
Um, my, my thing was the whole issue with
Eddie Gallagher, uh, being pardoned for war
crimes and yeah, and just today a daily piece
article was put out where Donald Trump wants
to use the uh, or criminals as essentially
his campaign motivation going forward.
Yup.
He wants them to go and campaign for him.
And this is so, listen, this, this is the
reality.
Earlier this week Trump did a press conference
with a military dog and it's clear Trump doesn't
care about the dog.
It's just how can I use the dog to try to
look good?
It's always about what can you do for Trump?
Nothing is about actual values or political
philosophy because Trump really has none.
And case in point, it was absolutely ridiculous
that Donald Trump said, Hey, war criminals
doesn't matter.
You can get out, but now you need to do work
for me and you need to campaign for me.
By the way, who said, this is totally aside
from whether it would benefit Trump to have
pardoned war criminals campaigning for him.
Maybe it would help them with people on the
right.
I don't think people on the left would be
too thrilled with that.
But what we get down to is it's just all about
what can you do for Trump?
How can you, excuse me?
How can you, uh, show your, uh, unending loyalty
to Trump?
And if he's done you a favor of some kind,
then how are you going to repay him?
Right.
Uh, in my opinion, this kind of sounds, it's
toeing the line with bribery.
In other words,
that's how Trump operates.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Right, right.
And I just can't tell, I don't know why people
don't see that.
Um, I know, I know a couple people that I
serve that can see right through that, but
there's many others that just, they see this
as a, when they see this as, Hey, is there
ISIS?
Hey there, they're the enemy anyways.
Cares.
Yup.
This is, so when Trump worked in real estate,
this is how we operated, he would, this is
how Trump operated in real estate.
This is what happened with Ukraine.
This is what's happening here.
It's it, it's what happens with, and by the
way, with, with ambassadorships, it's bigger
than Trump.
This is just how ambassadorships work in the
United States and it's sickening.
But this is how the guy operates.
That's it.
You've identified it,
right?
Um, yeah.
Thank you for taking my call, David.
Um, I just want to let you know that I'm a
regular listener and, uh, I'm pretty active
on the subreddit, so, uh, thank you.
All right, very good.
Great to hear from you.
Appreciate the call.